so
ah
foreign
good morning dear colleagues
the sitting is open one announcement
from my side
uh in relation to the decisions by the
pesh import and liber committees to
enter
into inter-institutional negotiations
pursuant to rule
71 paragraph 1 announced at the opening
of the sitting
last monday 2nd of may
i have received the requests for vote in
parliament pursuant to rule 71 paragraph
2 from the id and ecr groups
reaching at least the medium threshold
on the decisions of the liber committee
to enter into negotiations on the two
proposals for regulations concerning
the eu digital covet certificate
and the votes will be held tomorrow
concerning the other decisions to enter
into negotiations i have received no
request
for a vote in parliament by members or a
political group or groups reaching at
least the medium threshold and therefore
the committees may have started
um
may start the negotiations on the basis
of these
reports
the next item on the agenda is a council
and commission statements the social
and economic consequences for the
european union of the russian war
in ukraine reinforcing the european
union's capacity to act
i'll start by giving the floor to
brigitte clincare for the council
appreciate you have the floor
okay
oh
[Music]
an opportunity
is
[Music]
energetic
[Applause]
and now i invite the president of the
european commission also on their line
to take the floor
thank you madam president roberta
minister
honorable members
next week we will mark europe day
it is the 72nd birthday of our union
and
on this europe day we will talk about of
course the future of our union how we
make it stronger more resilient
closer to the people
but the answer to all these questions we
cannot give alone alone in these days
the answer is also given in ukraine
it is given in kharkiv where ukrainian
first responders venture into the combat
zone to help those wounded by russian
attacks
it is given in the small town of bucha
where survivors are coping with the
atrocities
committed against civilians by russian
soldiers
and it is given these days in mario paul
where ukrainians are resisting a russian
force which greatly outnumbers them
because they are fighting to reaffirm
basic ideas
that they are the master of their future
and not a foreign leader
that it is the international law that
counts and not the right of might
and that poutine must pay a price a high
price for his brutal aggression
thus the future of our european union is
also written in ukraine
and therefore
today i would like to speak about two
topics
first about sanctions
and second about relief and
reconstruction for ukraine
today we are presenting our sixth
package of sanctions
first we are listing high-ranking
military officers and individuals who
committed war crimes in butcher
and those who are responsible for the
inhuman siege of the city of mario paul
this sends another important signal to
all perpetrators of the kremlin
we know who you are we will hold you
accountable you're not getting away with
this
second
we finally d swift spare bank
spare bank is one of the is the largest
russian bank it holds round about 37
percent of the whole banking sector
and we will also d swift to other major
banks in russia
by that
we hit banks that are systemically
critical to the russian financial system
and putin's ability to wage destruction
this will solidify the complete
isolation of the russian financial
sector from the global system
third
we're banning three big russian
state-owned broadcasters from our
airwaves
they will not be allowed to distribute
their content anymore in the european
union in whatever shape or form
be it on cable via satellite on the
internet or via smartphone apps
we have identified these tv channels as
mouthpieces
that amplify putin's lies and
propaganda aggressively
and we should not give them a stage
anymore to spread these lies
fourth
the kremlin relies on accountants
consultants and spin doctors from europe
and this will now stop
we're banning those services from being
provided in russian to russian companies
and my final point number five
on sanctions is oil
when the leaders met in versailles they
agreed to phase out our dependency on
russian fossil fuels
in the last sanctioned package as you
know we started with coal
today we are addressing our dependency
on russian oil and let's be clear
it will not be easy
because some member states are strongly
dependent on russian oil
but we simply have to do it
so today we will propose
to ban all russian oil from europe
this will be
this will be a complete import ban on
all russian oil seaborn and pipeline
crude and refined
we will make sure that we phase out
russian oil in an orderly fashion
so in a way that allows us and our
partners to secure alternative supply
routes and at the same time be very
careful
that we minimize the impact on the
global market
and this is why we will phase out
russian supply of crude oil within six
months
and refine products by the end of the
year
thus we maximize the pressure pressure
on russia
while at the same time and this is
important we minimize the collateral
damage to us and our partners around the
globe because to help ukraine
we have to make sure that our economy
remains strong
honourable members
with all these steps
we are depriving the russian economy
from its ability to diversify and to
modernize
putin wanted to wipe out ukraine from
the map
and he will clearly not succeed on the
contrary
ukraine has risen in bravery and in
unity
and it is his own country russia that
putin is
sinking
honourable members
we want ukraine to win this war
but we also want to set the condition
for ukraine's success in the aftermath
of the war
and this is my second point relief and
reconstruction
the first step is immediate relief
this is about short-term economic
support
to help ukraine's cope with the fallout
of the war
we have done a lot already let me remind
you our micro financial assistant
package
or the direct support to the ukrainian
budget
in addition we recently proposed to
suspend all import duties on ukrainian
exports to our union for one year
and i'm sure that the european
parliament will put its weight behind
this idea in this proposal
but we all know this is not enough for
the short-term relief
ukraine's gdp
is expected to fall by 35 to 50
this year alone
and the imf estimates that from may on
ukraine ukraine needs 5 billion euros
per month
plain and simply to keep the country
running so to pay pensions to pay
salaries to provide for basic services
we have to support them
but i also know that we cannot do this
alone so i very much welcome that the
united states announced massive
budgetary support and we as two team
europes we have to do our share too
but then in a second phase
there's the wider reconstruction effort
and you all know that the scale of the
destruction is staggering hospitals and
schools houses roads bridges railroads
theaters factories you just name it so
much has to be rebuilt
of course in the fog of war it is
difficult to come up with a precise
estimate
but economists are talking about several
hundred billion euros
and here honorable members
i think europe has a very special
responsibility towards ukraine
with our support
and of course with the help of the
international financial institutions and
other global partners
ukraine can rebuild their country for
the next generation
and this is why today i propose to you
that we start working on an ambitious
recovery package for our ukrainian
friends
if we do it right
this package should bring massive
investments to meet the needs and the
necessary reforms in parallel
so it should address the existing
weaknesses of the ukrainian economy
and lay the foundation for sustainable
long-term growth
it could set a system of milestones and
targets to make sure that the european
money
truly delivers to the people of ukraine
and is spent in accordance with european
rules
it could help fight corruption we have
to do that it could align the legal
environment with european standards
and radically upgrade ukraine's
productive capacity and this will bring
the stability and the certainty
that is needed to make ukraine an
attractive destination for foreign
direct investment
and eventually honorable members
it will pave the way
for ukraine's future inside the european
union slava ukrainia long-lived europe
thank you very much
commission